bonsoir mesdames et messieurs vous les
avez peut-être entendu ou vu aujourd'hui
ce matin surtout montréal québec
trois-rivières un peu partout les
chauffeurs de taxi encore une fois
qu'ils exprimaient leur colère vis-à-vis
hubert cette compétition qu'ils jugent
déloyale
je rejoins est tout de suite à montréal
laurent thériault laurent un message au
premier ministre il lui demande
d'intervenir dans ce dossier
oui il lui demande surtout de préciser
sa pensée sur hubert ex patrice le
premier ministre couillard il ya une
dizaine de jours avait laissé entendre
qu'il pourrait légiférer en faveur du
ber x vous comprendrez que ça n'a pas
plu à l'industrie du taxi qui est
descendue en masse aujourd'hui dans les
rues du québec pour demander justement
qu'il prenne position
je vous laisse entendre deux
représentants de cette industrie là qui
ont participé aujourd'hui à ces
manifestations importantes
monsieur couillard vous ne pouvez plus
vous cacher derrière des déclarations
qui sont floues soit vous êtes en faveur
du brics où vous êtes content
et si vous êtes contre vous devez
appliquer les lois qui sont en vigueur
qu'on espère ne pense le plus vite
possible parce que sinon ils vont en
avoir d'autre chose qui va se produire
parce qu'on cherche repas écrasé comme
ça avec des politiques semblables dont
le ministre des transports encore une
fois j'allais dire s'est rangé du côté
des taxis moi il est catégorique patrice
hubert xc du transport illégal et c'est
une concurrence déloyale pour
l'industrie du taxi
il promet de légiférer dès cet automne
et d'ailleurs les représentants
d'industries du taxi sont allés porter
une lettre directement au bureau du
premier ministre aujourd'hui pour qu'il
y ait justement une loi dès cet automne
vous allez entendre robert poëti nous
dire que depuis les dernières semaines
depuis qu'il a rencontré l'industrie du
taxi
il y a eu des progrès importants de
réaliser on va l'écouter un mois la
différence de l'industrie du taxi qui se
sont pris en main mais moi je pense que
c'est de bonne augure et c'est une
menace pour eux mais ce que je leur ai
dit est invité à 20 prenez cette menace
en opportunité
et berrics aujourd'hui a un peu mis de
l'huile sur le feu patrice puisqu'ils
ont offert à leurs abonnés du québec des
courses gratuites et ils ont offert aux
chauffeurs d'augmenter la part qu'ils
reçoivent lors des courses
ce sera évidemment à suivre merci
d'ailleurs on a au téléphone jean
nicolas guilmette directeur général
d'hubert québec et monsieur guilmette
bonsoir à vous pour le 3 ce n'est pas
carrément de la provocation une journée
une manifestation des chauffeurs de taxi
qui tentent de gagner leur vie que
d'arriver à montréal et 10 ans avez-vous
nous aujourd'hui on est tellement plus
fun tout le monde
on va offrir les courses gratuites
écoutez nous l'objectif aujourd'hui
était bien à part dit ça ce qui est
montréal et lorsqu'on a fait ses comptes
et études avoir un appartement puis on
offre régulièrement des cours gratuits
aux nouveaux utilisateurs de qu'on a
fait aujourd'hui on leur dit vous n'avez
jamais été la plate forme d'une bonne
journée pour le faire que de toujours
dont on peut être sûr d'avoir beaucoup
partenaires répondent à la demande des
montréalais mais monsieur guide m vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne journée pour
attirer de nouveaux clients alors que
l'industrie que vous compétitionner vous
le voyez vous le constatez vous lisez
les journaux et excédés et on peux plus
écouter il ya deux soirs tenait la
première c'est qu'on ne comprend pas les
imprime tech et au noir derrière tous
les matins donc on offre un service
supplémentaire la population relève les
gens d avoir plus d'options
les familles québécoises leur deuxième
poste de dépense aujourd'hui se déplacer
on cherche à combattre l'auto solo et
depuis qu'on est ardent mourad qu'on a
bu et qui ne lui trouve selon la
commission des transports du québec
aucune belle dans la valeur des phases
de tact au cours des deux dernières
années sauter les deux années où on
était présente donc ce qu'on souhaite
faire nous c'est après plus de trente
ans mais monsieur qui vous laisse
savourer bien et que je savais très bien
que c'est un service qui compétitionne à
toutes les grandes villes du monde
d'ailleurs aller les taxis et de la
planète
et là vous êtes vous avez dit la semaine
dernière vous êtes prêts à donner au
gouvernement dissout la course taxi
est-ce que c'est pas encore rire du
monde alors que les chauffeurs paient
des impôts les chauffeurs paient des
permis de taxi vous paye rien du tout
zéro point barre vous offrez dissout la
course avaient tous les partenaires
chopard sur la plateforme près de
l'impôt à partir du 1er de l'an qui
génère comme tous les québécois et pour
qui tu sur les travailleurs autonomes
donc ils ont l'exemption de taxes pour
les premiers travail et de rap dictons
et par la suite ils paient ddps et des
vécus comme tous les autres entreprises
au québec
donc c'est faux de dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'impôt qui est payé et la cour de
toutes sortes et une fautif qui était
fait dans d'autres devises 54 sublime un
cadre réglementaire et même chose
toronto ottawa on vous a perdu une
seconde mais mais parce que là vous me
répondez quelques règles un peu mais ils
payent l'impôt si égale plus que
trentenaire ce que je vous dis c'est que
vous savez très bien vous les chauffeurs
ne paie pas de permis de taxi et c'est
considéré par tout le monde comme du
transport illégal de passagers alors ma
question en terminant est très simple
est ce que vous allez vous asseoir avec
le gouvernement du québec pour négocier
une vraie entente combien de vues
ailleurs à bostens par exemple où vous
allez continuer à compétitionner
légalement écoutez depuis les tout
débuts avant même quand la bête on
double notre objectif a toujours été
d'avoir un nouveau cadre et plein
d'autres comme il entraîne sa part à
toronto et maintenant on va construire
notre objectif c'est à port avec le
gouvernement crée un nouveau cadre il a
assuré qu on arrive à rien d'attendre
parce que plus de 75% des montréalais il
faut le rappeler comment sondage léger
marketing porte barricadée qui demande
dans le crime violent alaton également
donc c'est notre objectif ou si c'est ce
qu'on peut accomplir avec le
gouvernement libéral est allé négocier
veulent et négocie très bien vous
suivent ça ce qui met au revoir